we go either we go either succeed or die
trying' is it is what it is you can't
control like where your gifts come from
you can only do something about a mark
you can't completely go off numbers to
try to sale something creative you have
to come up with other creative ways to
sell it it isn't about what I have is me
knowing my weaknesses and what I don't
have
hello believe nation it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is that if you see
in yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn from singer and songwriter the
dream and my take on its top ten rules
of success rule number five is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best also as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below I
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired by it as well and if you
leave it within the first couple hours
of this video going live you have a
chance to win one of two daily prizes
I took everything that I learned from an
ethnic standpoint that my grandfather
taught me and put it into that I saying
if you pound talented as hard it
whatever thing in the same direction if
you keep hitting at a certain point it's
gonna break and then I open up so that's
what I did like it was like okay cool
this is what I'm doing my focus on this
thing we go either we go either succeed
or die trying it is what it is
I completely seen all the stars growing
up as human beings and I think that was
the first thing is in the first person
that I'm a human to me was Michael
Jackson if I would have ever seen him I
knew in my heart that I would treat him
like a person that has these talents you
can't control like what your gifts come
from you can only do something about
them or you know go through life and try
to make sure that you leave an
impression on this world with what what
you have on the inside so whoever was
singing or writing I felt like I wanted
to be amongst them and I want to look up
appear to them like I wanted to be
exactly in line with those people and I
still see things that same way today I
just developed this sense of not wanting
to have to lean on somebody to get my
job done so eventually being around like
all these great producers like starting
of course with on Tricky's brother Laney
who actually signed me to my first
publishing contract after I wrote this
record called everything for b2k I just
picked up the drum machine started
watching it patterns like I understood
how to write make a record I knew what a
hook was I knew the B section was and
you're just musically trying to
understand those same things and now and
I grew up in the 80s where all of those
melodic records you know what happened
so for me it was like I can hear it like
a jukebox in my head I just needed to
get it out so but finding that you have
good producers that know how to it could
be the smallest thing like a kick like
Timbaland has this way of how he makes
his kicks and his snares like they're on
this little slide Pete but you have to
know what you're doing when you hear it
and so all these things I get to get in
and listen to them and
pick it up and steal now like I listen
to something is that oh okay that's how
how you doing in even new producers like
so along the way I just picked up that
drum machine and that keyboard and said
okay I need to know how to make a song a
hundred percent period every day use it
yeah without you needing anyone if it
comes just because at the moment if you
want to create and you call somebody and
they can't do it that day you don't want
to get frustrated and not be able to do
it so I learned how to do everything it
was it was the beat it was writing a
song and recording and engineering
myself Wow yes I remember um writing
that song and it was saying that she was
finished I was in Vegas working on I
think love versus money at the time and
they were saying that she was finished
doing her album I said uh not if you
write a great song she's not you know
and so we wrote a song I remember going
back to Atlanta and Rick called me he's
like you know Celine's taking one song
coffee she putting this song on she
loves it it was like alright well you
know get it popular then I think the
conversation led into I think she had
tried to cut the vocal like a couple
times in her way and she was being vocal
produced by somebody you know and she
just strapped everything and said no I
want to sing it how he sang it
with that type of five you know and and
that was the biggest thing coming from
Celine because you're like who who who
could who could tell anybody how to sing
something with a voice like how she had
but the fact she recognized five there's
a whole different idea they're not
trying to teach people that all the time
and they don't really get it because
most of the time they think it's about
singing and it's like no it's about a
feeling you know I get to be the
creative person that sits in that room
like but what some type of rational idea
and not just straight artists because I
understand even by running a business as
a songwriter people have to make money I
get that you know what I tried to apply
to it though is you can't completely go
off numbers to try to sell something
creative you have to come up with other
creative ways to sell it I was working
at some collection agency I was really
bad at it it was really bad Sallie Mae
no that's too good it was it's too good
I remember just calling and they say I
don't have it I'm like cool UAG for that
really early my money it's really bad
and I just started playing golf at that
particular time I stopped by the golf
course like 7:30 in the morning and I
got on the first tee at this golf course
called legacy and I sat there and I
called into my job and I quit
because I kind of figured that if I
didn't put a hundred percent into music
really I was never gonna actually be
great enough to stay in and so I quit my
job that day not knowing I was gonna pay
rent the next month and at that time I
didn't have a publishing deal and that
song is actually what got me a
publishing deal awesome so you believed
in yourself and like I said you got to
be crazy enough to believe in yourself
if it was all I've become an artist
right now what advice would you give
yourself
oh wow pray if you're with the label you
would probably you should probably just
pray to somebody believes in you like
that one person versus having a whole
staff
making sure you being yourself
individually you know overall just
overcoming the fears of not succeeding
in the eyes of what the public idea in
perception of succeeding is be yourself
at all times
never sell your soul to any machine okay
if I become an artist in I'm gonna stay
out because I'm gonna always be singing
my own I mean it isn't about what I have
is me knowing my weaknesses and what I
don't have can't trick me into what I am
good at it's nobody gonna write anything
on a blog that's gonna say dream sucks
at this yeah you you're lying like
that's not if you see me on the
basketball court they're probably my
fader weighing down enemy we could say
he can't play basketball
hmm you're right he can't write music
you've lost you but I could do anything
I broke myself as an artist at the age
of 29
if that isn't already hard enough you
know to do what I've done in a 10-year
period and in this span to even be
blessed enough to be sitting here in
front of you guys talking about this I
could wrap it up and say oh cool goals
done I'm just moving on but it's too
many other things you know once you're
moving from from one thing it's all art
to me it's all in a bowl like it's just
on a plate there's an ice cube I need to
chase now there's a dr. Dre I need to
chase down like this it's moved on from
Lionel and and Diane - now it's other
people that I see and say oh they use
that same brain to get those things and
I can use my brain to actually get to
the same things that you have so it's
just an everlasting idea to keep pushing
you know myself
this music things like water like it's
not my songs are gonna be my songs
regardless like people get hot and cold
and and wonder off but you'll be back
like and when you when it's time for you
to get married or fall in love again and
I'll be here
but this idea of what to do or what to
do next is what I've been doing all of
alone like these are just steps you know
I was already preparing to be able to
retire at a very early age and not
meaning retire you never see me again
but oh cool I could put my stuff and now
I can do whatever the to do you know but
still use myself in the things that I
see and the movies I want to write and
direct and bring them to the world
because there is nobody has any real
idea what's in my mind and heart sitting
on the stage you just know what I've
done and when I didn't when I didn't
have that stuff before you didn't know I
could do that
so we have no idea what I can actually
do we've seen great people come from
nothing so if you have something that
means that you should go to even higher
levels of achieving what your goals and
your dreams are I speak for all of us we
have no excuses we will go on to be
exactly who we want to be in pursuit of
the American dream in the summer of 1992
my mother was diagnosed with cancer
didn't know at the time how serious it
was but that summer was already a big
transition for me because they were
closing my high school I went which was
West Fulton so couldn't really get no
worse I never thought that I would lose
my mom at the end of this year after his
mother passed away his grandfather kept
him I raised him he provided Helen with
most everything he were asked for
I remember this graph fall apart of my
seller Jerome said he would be back in
his room playing at John I never bought
music
[Music]
Who I am as a father I took my
responsibilities as a the father very
very heavy I try to do the best that I
can with what I have try to make sure
that I can provide a better way and
provide more choices and options for my
children that I've got to come behind me
you know life is from generation to
generation building on choices
[Music]
who are loaning me that is putting it
all
I had 10 choices in ten directions I
could go there my children should have
100 and their children should have a
thousand that's basically what it is me
knowing that the sacrifices I had to
make you know with my grandfather
working all day and my mother working in
no way deters me how to be a great
father in anyone's book is set in stone
or black and white there's no real way
to do it there are only your gifts your
opportunities in your choices to do the
best that you can
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because you guys asked
me to if there's someone you like me to
profile in their future top ten please
check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick shout out to Benny
Alex Benny thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book your one word and
that awesome message that you had to
share I'm so glad is having an impact on
your life and thank you for sharing it
and put it on Twitter too I really
really appreciate the support thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope we can't you need to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
by the time we get to about 2007 I'm
imagining you have more control your
vision is really shining through now
with a record called um umbrella Wow
yeah that record was done in an active I
would like to imagine Muhammad Ali on
the ropes and just taking it it's taking
a pounding lifeless I was out of my
publishing deal you don't know when the
stars are aligning it just depends on
how how much you can keep your head up
through it they could be aligning and
you not know it which is most of the
times I was checking pockets and stuff
like maybe I left extra 20 over here to
put some gas in this did you still have
a Cadillac with leather seats and I had
a Jaguar at the time don't say uh they
tried to repossess it like nine times I
hear that's good every time fog down the
street and walk to you apply medicine
cover this up with some leaves and it
was just so a weird space to say right
off hit you know the hit sounds like you
know what songs you like from other
people like you if you went to make a
playlist you knew it was you know you
know how to make it so just write a hit
so I just told myself that that day and
literally we're moving stuff around in
the studio cool Carell who who knows
like side by side with Rihanna records a
lot of her stuff for her now finds a
finds this loop this is kick loop tricks
tours starts to play this court and I
kind of walk in at that that same moment
and I hear it and I heard about maybe
eight bars of of what trick was doing I
say may turn the mic on it's like we're
not ready we just stopped moving it
around we don't gotta plug it up we got
to get it right like okay cool turn the
mic on
I turned the mic on I maybe had to go
back and change four words but I sung it
from the top to the end exactly as is
how you hit a song today right now